is there any specific moment that you
would attribute to
getting that feeling that you want to
come to terms with
you know your heritage and playing that
in movies more
yeah that's just happened like
just recently in the last couple of
years and i think it has a lot to do
with like the
collective cultural awakening that's
been going on
um with not only like
the metoo movement but also black lives
matter and
just this like reckoning we're all going
through i think as a society right now
and so when i was
coming up in the game like because it
was like
i really feel like hollywood is
so lazy like they will just try to box
you in
because they just don't want to do the
work of thinking you can do more than
that
and so i always was afraid
one that playing too many middle eastern
parts was going to
pigeonhole me but also i had this thing
where
i felt like when i got a middle eastern
role that people were going to think
the only reason i got it was because it
was middle eastern like not because
i was talented and there was also this
thing that would happen
in my career where like i would get cast
even
in a role that was just like a white
role just a normal role whatever
white maybe not white like just had a
normal
non-ethnic name and then
after casting me they would want to
change my character's name to something
middle eastern
many times and i used to not
like the first time that happened i
asked them not to do that and they
were cool with it and they heeded my
wish and the reason was that
i'll tell you why it bothered me was
that it's not like they had written a
middle eastern role
or a an ethnic role to give an
opportunity to an ethnic
actor instead i had to compete
with a pool of white actors who are
afforded a lot more opportunities than i
am and i win for my
talent and my merit and then they want
to get points for diversity after the
fact
and that's not right to me it's like you
didn't you should have done this before
then
because i didn't want the perception to
be that i only competed with 10 girls
for this part
when the reality was i had competed with
400 girls for the part
um but as time went on and i
began to really understand how important
visibility was
and inclusion is and that if i hid
behind some whitewashed version of
myself
or like you know why wash the name of a
character then
how was that visibility gonna really
happen and i started to realize you know
what it's less about what this
character's name is
and it's more about what kind of
character this is
and so it's like it's fine if you want
to like it happened actually in snow
piercer like originally my character's
name was cleo
and all of a sudden when things changed
behind the scenes there i became
zara farami and i had a moment where i
was like do i want to do this
and i realized you know what maybe it's
a good thing we need to see
middle eastern people on screen to show
hollywood that like
we can play ball and also just like for
culture for representation
so i had a conversation with them of
like that's okay i'm down with this but
i just don't want
it to now become followed by a slew of
other stereotypes
and so um they were cool with that too
and we had the conversation and they
assured me that like i wasn't
suddenly gonna become you know similar
with like
when i did 24 legacy and they were
you know coming after me pretty hard to
play that role i
i told them like the only way i'll do
this is if you never
make my character a terrorist in this
show there cannot be some twist where
i'm the one who's the bad guy and they
assured me of that as well
so it's basically been this dance of
like getting
into being i mean also like you know
undoing and unlearning like
internalized white supremacy to be quite
frank like
growing up i did feel like all those
things that get put into our minds that
that i don't know white is more american
and
white is prettier and and more valid in
some way
and um and of course i want to just
acknowledge i know i'm a light-skinned
iranian girl so
i have benefited from that and i'm not
you know that i'm not happy about that
makes me sad that um
a darker skinned actress just as good as
me might not get something just because
of that that's
extremely messed up and i'm glad the
world is now changing
um but i yeah i've started to with this
whole
tide and sea change of inclusion and
representation i'm like of course i want
to be part of that
um and uh yeah so so so i'm embracing it
way more and just getting a little more
involved
behind the scenes which was also scary
to do when i was younger because like i
said i just like
never wanted to get fired and i was
always made to feel so disposable
and replaceable so now i'm like you know
but you can't get that without some
experience and age like now i'm like
i don't need i don't need you um you you
need me
so i i'm happy to hear that now
yeah i i so yeah it's it's about having
enough of those conversations where you
protect yourself from
suddenly becoming a radical muslim just
because you're playing a middle eastern
role
you